anyway here with more Fox News White
House correspondent our friend Peter
Ducey as well as sir how are you
doing well Sean thank you all right
the fact you asked a legitimate question
we set a record ten thousand illegal
immigrants in a day and she gets all
pissed off that you dared to ask that
question
and I I personally thought she was
answering the question with a question
so I was answering if I if I misread the
room there uh that's on me but something
that we heard them say today is that yes
uh immigration it's a problem that has
been going on for many years that is
true however that includes two and a
half years of this Administration and
just a few minutes ago President Biden
was at a Gala in Washington DC and he
was talking about how the first piece of
legislation that he put forward on his
first day in office was this
comprehensive immigration reform they
sent it to Congress and it failed so he
is saying that border problems now are
because Republicans voted against his
day one immigration measure that they
did vote against it but in Washington DC
you are allowed to put legislation
forward more than once and so they keep
going back to this day one uh we tried
and uh it's not our fault anymore I that
doesn't necessarily have to be the case
just if you look at the way that the
system is set up uh something else that
they've been trying to do over the last
couple years and you touched on this
with that app that they have they want
people to apply for Asylum somewhere
else and then come when they get cleared
in
that just hasn't been working uh and why
would people
apply really uh somewhere else if these
folks are able just to walk in
circumvent the system and get relocated
to a different uh to a big U.S city and
I've been thinking a lot about this
because last week uh and the week before
we were traveling internationally with
the president we were in India and
Vietnam and the process to get into a
foreign country as an American very
complicated you gotta file a Visa you
got to pay a fee uh and then you got to
go through a pretty comprehensive
security checkpoint I none of that is
happening here and so there are
international systems that are in place
uh the the rules that you generally
would expect as anybody who is traveling
uh are not necessarily being followed
and this Administration is not I they're
not coming up with anything else like it
is a problem that keeps getting worse 10
000 people in 24 hours is near an
all-time high that is not a problem that
is getting better and the question that
I was trying to ask what do they call
that because they want to take credit
for some small economic improvements
economic policy they call it Dynamics
well what is the immigration policy and
we'll try again to find out tomorrow oh
Biden's borders uh how does it feel to
be just flat out lied to and they say
the border is closed and secure when we
all know it's not Peter how do you deal
with that
I'm just there to figure out what they
think is going to happen next like what
are they doing and I again we will keep
asking and it would be great to have a
chance to ask the president that uh in
the early days of the administration we
had many many chances to talk to the
President part of that was because the
rooms were for social distancing reasons
it was just the president and the Press
uh there are many many fewer chances to
talk to the president as we go but it
would be great to hear from him you'll
remember he did go visit the Border uh a
couple weeks after I asked him why he
was going out west and not visiting and
he said that there was other stuff going
on uh he did go so presumably he
understands what's happening uh and uh
it would be great to hear from him or
from the vice president who you will
remember is in charge of the root causes
of migration because these are not just
people coming from Mexico they're coming
from all over the world through Mexico
and um I will try to find out but as far
as we know she's still on it just be
careful he did call you uh an SOB once
yeah you know I'm just imagining if you
say you're lying and the borders are
wide open and they're not secure he's
not going to like you
but I don't think he likes uh you anyway
because you're the only one that asks
fair questions hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else